this week on brian ross investigates
it was one of the ugliest days in
american history
immortalized by hollywood in the movie
selma
four schoolgirls killed by a ku klux
klan bomb
at the 16th street baptist church in
birmingham alabama
it took decades to get full justice for
those responsible
and only because prosecutor and future
senator doug jones
would not let the case drop now jones
joins us to talk
about another pivotal court case sure to
make history
the trial of police officer derrick
schultz
plus vaccine phobia as the biden
administration made
too much of the issues with johnson and
johnson's vaccine
or not enough all 50 states have now
paused johnson johnson shots
as regulators meet today to investigate
those six cases of rare
but potentially fatal blood clots and
how long will we need to still wear
masks outdoors
when the risk is so low we're joined by
dr
boris lustia the former acting surgeon
general
and this week's winners and losers in
the media
see if you agree with the choices made
by the editors of meaty heights
but ted cruz needs to look in the mirror
which can be tough
especially for him from the lawn crime
trial network
this is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live
i'm brian ross joined as always by my
colleague rhonda schwartz
and ron and we begin with the trial of
derek chovin
in the courtroom it was all about the
guilt or innocence of this one
former minneapolis police officer
accused of the murder of george floyd
but outside the courtroom in minneapolis
really across the country and around the
world
there's a much greater significance in
the search for racial and social justice
it is a quest ronda that has often been
denied or delayed
and for decades rhonda
that's right brian from the fictional
story of to kill a mockingbird
to the real-life drama of some of the
country's darkest moments in the civil
rights movement
forgotten by many but immortalized by
hollywood
i love her i heard she don't put rollers
and it's just like that
but i study i know how she do it see she
parts in the middle
and then
it took decades for full justice for the
ku klux klan members who planted the
bomb
at the 16th street baptist church in
birmingham alabama
in 1963 and the final prosecution came
only after the then u.s attorney and
future u.s senator doug
jones pushed for action when he was a
u.s attorney in the early 2000s
jones brought two white supremacists to
justice
decades after a deadly attack it was for
their involvement in the 1963
birmingham church bombing four young
black girls
aged 11 to 14 were killed when a bomb
exploded
at the 16th street baptist church in
birmingham alabama
more than 10 years later in 1977
a white supremacist named robert
chomless
was convicted of murder for
participating in the bombing
then in the year 2000 the fbi announced
that three other men were also involved
one of them was already dead but the
other two were tried
convicted and sentenced to life
in prison and we're joined now by former
prosecutor doug jones and former u.s
senator
doug thanks so much for joining us you
made history with the prosecution
in alabama how do you think the trial of
derek shoving will be regarded
by historians in future years in terms
of the ability to find
social and racial justice in this
country
well you know brian first of all thanks
for having me it's a real pleasure to be
with you guys today uh i am hoping
uh that this is going to go down in the
annals of history
as a significant event because if derek
chovin is convicted it will be in large
measure because of the breakdown
in the what they've called the blue wall
of silence it is very difficult i can
tell you as both a prosecutor's defense
lawyer it's difficult
to convict a police officer law
enforcement officer
of a criminal uh act uh with even when
there is a death occurred
and so what we've seen in this case i
believe
is not just the the outcry and the
cries for social justice that was
prompted by the death
of george floyd but what we've seen in
this trial in particular
was a very methodical way that the
prosecution laid out a case
and they used police officers his fellow
police officers
on that minneapolis police force to make
the case that what he did was
outside not just the norm but outside
the bounds of the law
so that's where i believe this case is
really going to have some significance
for law enforcement
and for justice as the prosecutor said
today this is actually not an anti-law
enforcement case
this is a pro-law enforcement case and i
completely agree with that
exactly it was the closing argument
there this is a pro-police case
why is that appeal necessary for jurors
do you think because there's such a
trust and
belief in the assignment of police
officers and their responsibilities
it's not just a trust and belief it is a
you want to believe you want to put your
faith in there
after all these law enforcement officers
are there for you as well they're there
for those members of the community
that are sitting in that jury box that
are sitting in judgment
of the police officer so that you know i
don't like to use the word given the
benefit of the doubt but they do to some
extent
they want to make sure that they get
this right and so it is that trust it is
that enforcement
it is that knowing that they've got to
do the right things to
allow the law enforcement the leeway to
protect the community and use the force
necessary but when they cross that line
they need to hold them accountable
doug a question for you from rhonda
schwartz rhonda
in the history of the civil rights
movement where would you put the derek
shoving trial and this moment in time
where we've seen so much unrest in the
streets again
where does it fit into the timeline is
are we making is it a big step forward
where are we at now
yeah you know rhonda it's a great
question because i think it's a huge
step forward
what happened with george floyd really
changed some dynamics around here you
know the pandemic
really put a spotlight on the racial
disparities that we've known existed in
this country
we've known for a long time in health
care and jobs and the economy
and we've known they've existed in law
enforcement but when in the middle of
this pandemic
people at home people sequestered in
their homes they saw the death of this
black man with a police officer's knee
on his neck the way it was all of a
sudden people just
rose up uh in anger and a lot of people
woke up and said we understand now those
of us who've been preaching this for a
long time got it we've known about it
but
there's a lot of folks in this country
who just didn't see it that way until
they saw those images
since that time we we've kind of pulled
back a little bit we've seen some
violence that kind of took away the
message
i really hope that this that this case
will once again reignite the idea that
we need to have some significant law
enforcement reform
and reignite the debate that we've got
about race in this country
not just in law enforcement but across
the spectrum of american life
doug what specific reforms do you think
are required or necessary
for policing in this country well
there's a couple of things brian and i
was a co-sponsor when i was in the
senate of the
george floyd police reform act it passed
the house of representatives
twice now it died in the senate it never
got a vote
uh in the senate uh there's any number
of things that i believe that can happen
let's let's talk about transparency
there needs to be more transparency
in these excessive force uh um reviews
and investigations i like to have
citizens in birmingham
uh just today the mayor of birmingham
randall woodman announced a review
commission to look at these and have
citizens and former police officers on
there as well
i think that transparency is very
important
i think having a registry of some type
that these law enforcement excessive
force allegations that are made
can travel with these these folks
sometimes they just get buried and
people can move around
and no one knows that they've had any
number of complaints
against them i think more funding needs
to be made
uh and had by at the federal and local
level for training
particularly both racial sensitivity
training as well as de-escalation
training
that's what caused so many of the
problems last year is that
between police officers and those out in
the in the streets
that no one tried to de-escalate this
and we've got to do that
and finally i think we've got to look at
the obvious things the no knock warrants
the chokeholds
those need to be taken away from from
law enforcement they're not
necessary and finally we're going to
look at whether or not qualified
immunity
uh needs to be stricken the judges are
looking at that
i think congress and the state laws have
to take a look at qualified immunity
i don't know if it needs to be
completely gotten rid of
but it sure needs to be tweaked such
that we can balance out
the needs of law enforcement but allow
communities allow
families to have that redress that they
deserve in the court system
and finally from the 16th street baptist
church bombing to
derek chauvin trial do you see progress
real progress
being made in terms of the search for
social and racial justice
brian i think that's the the 64 000
question right now
have we have we seen that yes we have
seen it but we have
also seen some serious backsliding in
the last few years
it stems in everywhere from voting
rights to law enforcement
i think what we have seen in the last
four years and particularly
we've seen a lot of public officials
including the president of the
former president of the united states
using what we in the south called dog
whistle
kind of rhetoric it kind of gives a
green light and a wide rise
of white supremacy that is taking over
people need to stand up a little more
they need to do exactly what john lewis
channel everyone needs to channel their
inner john lewis and stand up speak out
cause a little good trouble because we
have got to move this country
in a way that everyone is equal everyone
is
treated equally and fairly in both
business society
and especially our system of justice
all right former u.s senator former
federal prosecutor doug jones thank you
so much for being
with us here tonight my pleasure brian
thank you
up next covet 19 vaccine the phobia
and the mania we'll talk with former
acting surgery general dr
boris lushniak you're watching brian
ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
as of this week every adult in america
is eligible to receive a covet 19
vaccine
and according to the cdc at least half
of adult americans have already received
at least one dose
but behind that good news are some
troubling questions about
vaccine safety and vaccine phobia
so to get some answers for that we're
joined by our good friend dr boris
lushnia who's the dean
of the school of public health at the
university of maryland and the former
acting
surgeon general dr lozniak thank you
once again for joining us
thanks for having me on again brian
great to see you
with questions now about the johnson and
johnson vaccine and distribution held up
that is not good for public confidence
is it
you know it's it's one of those
situations where there's there's good
news and there's bad news out of this
one thing is most importantly is that we
have to monitor the adverse events that
are reported with each of the vaccines
that are out there don't forget that
these are brand new vaccines
and this is a brand new campaign of
trying to immunize
all of the united states at some point
all of the world right with brand new
vaccines
so we have to take this sense of of any
reported adverse events quite seriously
so the bad news is we found something
that is of concern
right the good news is something's being
done about it so we put a hold on the
johnson johnson vaccine
there's going to be a re-analysis of
what's really going on
and hopefully in the next few days we'll
either get a thumbs up to move ahead
or or we'll get further information to
either ease our minds or to tell us to
be
a little bit more vigilant in the midst
of all this as a public health person
this is the right approach at this
stage of a vaccine campaign
yet it has given ammunition to the
anti-vaxxers and the feeding of
a vaccine phobia we had a program last
week with
evangelical christians about 40 percent
don't want to take the vaccine
as a public health expert how do you
counter that how do you deal with that
well again you have to come up with the
facts that this is data-driven
information and so i
ask anybody who's a skeptic over the
vaccine look at the facts
two things are very really critical with
with the release of a vaccine
such as the vaccines that we have
against covet 19.
one is are they working and the reality
is
they are working look at the information
that's out there
it has really decreased the number of
hospitalizations for people who are
vaccinated
it has decreased the number of people
who die from covid who have been
vaccinated
and in fact even these breakthrough
covet 19 scenarios are very small in
numbers so what a
protects us from the disease overall in
terms of the safety effects once again
you have to look at this realistically
right seven million doses of
johnson johnson vaccine were given and
right now we're reacting to
six people yes this is a serious adverse
event one person died one person is in
serious condition
this is important that we not neglect
this that we not
ignore this but we move ahead get the
right information
and then at the end of the day i want to
be able to prove through veda
through data that the vaccines work and
in fact they are
safe dr lakshniak a question for you
from rhonda schwartz rhonda
so where does the future how does it
look to you are we all going to be able
to get together by memorial day or is it
going to be labor day
what what do you look see ahead in the
next few months
you know it all depends on how things go
regarding the vaccines a lot of
unknowns are still out there so first of
all as i mentioned already
vaccines are working and they are safe
so we have an incredible campaign as
brian had stated
over half of americans have received one
dose this is an incredible public health
achievement for the good of our country
at the same time the virus keeps
changing right and so we have to be able
to monitor these variants of the virus
we have to be able to see whether that
virus changes enough for us to be
concerned
i'm an optimist rhonda when it comes to
this i'm really looking forward the
middle of summer really being a game
changer for the way we
are dealing with this pandemic it's not
going to be an all clear necessarily
but it's going to be a changed
environment if we do
things correctly and doctor to follow up
on that there's something called the
vaccine mania with
so many people now uh vaccinated they
want to take their masks off
in israel in fact they're no longer
requiring masks outside
do we really need to wear a mask
outdoors if we've been vaccinated
well for now i'm i'm really sort of
touting the cdc recommendations on this
right
so to the listeners to the audience out
there look at what cdc is saying
in general right now we're still
advising the use of mass
hand washing being careful with large
crowd situations the idea of physical
distancing
why because i'm a little afraid that if
people feel that they are
fully fully protected from the back from
the covet 19
because they've been vaccinated that
this may lead to setbacks
rather than taking a very conservative
approach
right the vaccine takes a while to kick
in at the same time we still have to
prove that we are no longer infectious
even though we ourselves have been
vaccinated
a lot of unknowns are out there i'm just
asking everybody to be a little bit more
vigilant
a little bit more careful and give it a
little bit more time before we call
in all clear regarding this pandemic
it's going to happen but we have to do
it right
all right thank you very much once again
dr boris lesniak the dean of the
school of public health at the
university of maryland great thank you
for having me on
all right up next this week's winners
and losers in the media
see if you agree with the choices made
by the editors of mediaite
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime
trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite and we're joined as
always by
aidan mclaughlin who is the
editor-in-chief of mediaite which
like the law and crime trial network is
part of the dan abrams
media company and aiden we begin with
your winner john berman the co-host of
the cnn morning program
for his sharp commentary here's some of
that
look maxine waters needs to answer to
maxine waters she has said incendiary
things in the past and this is a week
where the nation is very much on
edge but ted cruz needs to look in the
mirror
which can be tough especially for him
because you know what they say when the
going gets tough
the pot goes to cancun
so aidan why john berman he's a great
writer when i worked with him at abc he
started as just a writer on the world
news worked his way up to correspondent
and left to cnn where he's now an anchor
yeah so he's an anchor at new day which
is cnn's breakfast show
which is supposed to compete with
morning joe on msnbc and fox and friends
over on fox news
um he also has a new co-host of
new day uh briana keilor who was a
anchor in the afternoon who has now
replaced allison camarada who was his
former co-host for a couple years
uh camarada has now moved to the
afternoons brianna keeler who uh made a
name for herself on cnn for sort of
fiery opinion segments has now moved to
join john berman in the mornings for new
day
um today was brianna keeler's first day
co-hosting
new day with john berman um but we
really thought that john berman stole
the show
today with this segment which was
calling out ted cruz's hypocrisy
on violent rhetoric ted cruz took issue
with maxine waters comment
about protesters in minneapolis berman
was pointing out that
ted cruz enabled donald trump up until
the january 6 riot
uh when uh trump's own violent rhetoric
uh caused the ransacking of the capital
uh so it was a smart segment and it's uh
it's a good
sort of revamp that new day's having
today uh and john berman uh
kicked it off to a good start we thought
and there's a mix then of news analysis
and some opinion
yeah you know new day has always been a
newsier morning show than
morning joe on msnbc which is obviously
uh liberal and
uh fox and friends on fox news which is
a little bit more conservative um
so it's always been a bit more of a news
program sort of in cnn's vein
uh of cable news um but it's gotten a
little bit more opinionated i think
over the years uh used to have chris
cuomo co-hosting with alison camerota
now it has briana keeler who's one of
cnn's more opinionated hosts
so edgy seems to work let's go to your
loser something called
oan tell our viewers what that is and
why they
are losers that's right so oen is a
pro-trump
news network uh that's run by robert and
charles herring
a father and son duo and it's sort of
similar to newsmax which is another
alternative to fox news
that embraced donald trump's fantasy
that he actually won the 2020 election
until it was stolen from him uh oen is
actually a little bit fringier than
newsmax even i would say it's
considerably more
conspiratorial and the new york times
did a lengthy expose on the network this
weekend
which interviewed a bunch of current and
former uh employees of oan
more than a dozen of them resigned from
the network after the january
6 riot because they saw that programming
as having fueled that
and you even had current employees of
oand who were going on the record
with the new york times saying that they
thought that it was a conspiratorial
network
that contributed to that riot one of
those staffers was fired today
overall it's a pretty bad week for a
network um that never is particularly
done very well in the headline and its
owner mr herring uh at
the center of it yeah that's true
that's pretty much why we made him loser
um he defended the network and comments
to the new york times
i don't think he's really convincing
anyone that uh it is a serious news
network or that it
is has any sort of rigorous uh news
deliverance
okay aidan mclaughlin once again
editor-in-chief of media
thank you so much for this week's
winners and losers and thanks to all of
you for watching tonight we'll see you
again next week
and thanks to our great staff at long
crime for getting us on and off the air
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you